all right so what i'm going to talk
about is uh
joint work with anderas krause and eta
zurich and his student
mario lucic and amin karbassi who was a
postdoc with andreas and now who is at
yale
and and clearly from the title you can
already see that we will have
lots of common themes with what champ
said and there will be also differences
so i'm going to not explicitly comment
on them mostly
unless you have you have a question then
i can actually go ahead and elaborate
more about how the two things relate
the idea is that we want to talk about
computation statistics trade-offs and
and really what is the what is at stake
here so we are very used to thinking of
data
as a statistical resource so more data
gives you
a naturally lower statistical risk but
typically we think of data as a
computational hindrance more data is
going to actually make life difficult
for you
so the par the paradigm in which we want
to think is can data be
thought of as a computational resource
can more data actually drive down your
computational cost
so this is the general thinking and the
roots of this
go far back in fact uh servio i don't
know i know he's here but i'm not sure
he's in the room right now
they had thought about all these ideas
and i'm going to talk to you today
about slightly different version of that
but
let's make this gradually more precise
it's one step at a time
so unlike what shum said so let's
compare a tiny bit i'm not going to
think about
competing with the rm i'm going to fix a
certain risk tolerance
which many applications is what you want
so you you say i want
to guarantee a certain statistical risk
so with that statistical risk is
associated the sample complexity of the
learning or estimation problem below
which if you have less data
than that you cannot solve the problem
now once you are
above that point typically you choose an
estimation algorithm it's going to have
certain
running time so here i'm plotting right
converts data size but as
you increase the data size typically
this algorithm is going to require more
and more time
it also is going to give you less and
less risk but we don't care
we only care about guaranteeing the
epsilon risk
now what you can do given this algorithm
is you can just take it and truncate
your data
and use it as is and that's going to
give you this flat line
in terms of it's some computation
statistics trade-off you're just
truncating
your algorithm but it's somewhat trivial
what we're asking more here is whether
we can have we can do something so once
you go beyond the sample complexity
unless you have more data than you need
can you leverage the fact that you have
more data in order to drive the
computational cost down
and does there exist such an algorithm
so does there exist a non-trivial
trade-off okay so
let's but why would we expect to be able
to even do this
where where where do we get the game
where does the computational gain come
from
so so for this i'm going to go back to
the classical bias variance picture
so our truth is somewhere out there
and we choose a model class as is
typically done in learning and stats
and the first item here is that we want
to
to find the best element in our model
class to describe the truth
i'm going to make this very precise in
the context of k-means in a few seconds
but for now let's just think abstractly
to see what's happening
now of course we don't have access to
even the the
the truth to be able to find the best in
best in class all we have is data
and based on that data we make an
estimation and that's
going to incur some variance so here
variance i'm using it not literally as a
variance but it's
it refers to the estimation error so
with more
so so let's say now we hit the right
risk error risk tolerance
what's happening typically in the
statistical problem is that with more
data we
can actually get lower estimation error
and we create a margin here a gap
between the estimation
the the risk that we can tolerate and
and what
the the straightforward algorithm
estimation algorithm is doing
now the idea is that we cannot fill this
gap with something coarser so instead of
finding this point
we find the coarser point out there this
orange part
and that's going to give that's going to
uh
to be uh where we we hope to gain in
computation
by doing this weaker estimation now just
to jump back a little bit what to do
what sham says so sram is comparing this
this this distance from this point to
that point that bull is blue distance
and is trying to make sure that they
grow
together or the ratio they'll actually
even
stay overlapping and then meanwhile gain
something from the fact that you're not
exactly on top of it
but right now we're just fixing our
tolerance and we're trying to fill this
gap
by doing something smart so let's make
this concrete
k-means problem also known as vector
quantization
and information theory and signal
processing so what's the problem here
hopefully i don't have to really
motivate it for you just i'm just going
to set up some notation
everybody has seen one version of this
i'm talking particularly about the
statistic of the probabilistic version
of this so we have an underlying
distribution
which we're trying effectively to
approximate by k points
and the way we judge the performance of
this approximation is by the proximity
of a sample
drawn from this distribution to one of
the centers
and we're trying to find our optimal
basically
is to minimize this this risk
anybody objects to the this is clear
right so
undergraduate maybe of course we all see
this
uh so now uh this is the problem we
cannot solve it
because we don't know p what we have is
access to data as
ramon was commenting earlier and we
solve instead the empirical variant so
this is going to be the de facto
algorithm against which i'm comparing
i'm glad
this question was asked to shum and he
said well we can perhaps do better
sometimes but now this is
our benchmark so this is the the typical
thing that people do
and if you optimize the empirical risk
we obtain the empirically optimal
centers
and these quantities can do not have to
be unique but for now just think that
there is a unique solution here unique
solution there
what do we know about this problem so
the empiric this came in statistical
chemist problem statistically
what we know about it in fact pollard in
the 80s
he solved almost everything that there
was to say about it about this problem
convergence com rates asymptotic
distribution
almost everything he established it
and then computationally what we know
about this problem here on the samples
is that
in general it's hard
and there are heuristics for it the
k-means algorithm is actually lloyd's
procedure to solve it
gives you something and often sometimes
you can show that it's really good
in the worst case it can be also bad and
recently there have been some polynomial
time approximation schemes to show that
yes you can solve it if you're willing
to approximate the problem you can solve
it
in polynomial time and and then
in practice what people use is variants
where uh you smartly initialize this
k-means problem
and then you can you can have certain
guarantees
so this is what we know we're not going
to commit so
the perspective i'm going to present i'm
not going to commit to a particular
solver so all that i'm going to think
about is that you have some solver that
solves this and it has some
computational
uh it offers some computational property
so we can't solve this problem and then
we're going to write everything in
function of that solver
in the background so so now in this
problem what is what is
what does that picture become the truth
is simply our distribution p
the model class is the class of all case
centers
the best in the model is c star they
estimate what we estimate from the data
is c
n hat and what we want to find is a
weaker estimate
okay meanwhile the modeling error is the
risk of c star
the estimation error is the expected
risk of the expectation
in the samples of the of the empirically
optimal centers
the difference between that and the
modeling error
and here this additional term is the
cost of our weakening
which hopefully will come with a gain in
computation something faster
relatively well well motivated
so how how do we weaken an estimation
how do we find such a point
so traditionally how has so now let's
think of this problem as just a genetic
risk here
going back to what uh sean was saying
uh this problem typically when the
problem underlying problem is convex
for example for support factor machine
for in in the work of
botu and busquets right and cerebral
they try to approximately solve this
using stochastic gradient descent which
is what shum
has refined another approach more
recently was chandrasekhar and jordan
they created a hierarchy
of uh convex relaxation which also
allows you
to well the solution will not be the
right point but it will be close enough
to the point and you will get some
computational gain
but the caveat in all these approaches
is that
they really need a convex problem to
work with
so what but what are they doing what
they're doing is that here we're
approximately solving
here we're changing a little bit the
constraint set
and what the other thing we can think
about doing is
to change the objective function to
approximate the objective function
and we're going to approximate this to
objective function using data
summarization
asking anything i'm not sure whether
anybody is following or
or it's too simple or too confusing so
i okay okay
so sure
let's go back to the picture yeah so
so all none of these are the two
relaxations to talk about
in the latest slide none of this is
changing the model class
so
that's also an option yes but those
populations were not
discussed what i'm talking about we're
fixing the molecules but definitely it's
something you can play around with
because when you what happens when you
change the model class what happens if
you change log
this shrinks so it gives you more room
but what what increases
is the estimation error so there's a
balance which is the model selection
balance basically
people in model selection that's what
they do they try to balance everything
but so what we're going to just
complicate the problem without getting
any insight if we do everything at the
same time
but it can definitely be done model
selection and computation statistics
tradeoffs at the same time
in fact in the beginning that's what i
was trying to do it was got too messy so
i decided to just look at the
fixed model class
great okay great question thank you
i'll charge you later okay
all right so how are we going to do this
approximation so this is the function
we're trying to approximate
we can think so this is the empirical
measure so it's associated with every
single point a weight of one over n
what we're going to do by when i say
summarize the data what i'm going to do
is i'm going to throw away some of these
points
and i'm going to assign different
weights to the remaining points
so we're going to replace effectively
the empirical distribution
by a weighted by some other
amplitude distribution reflectively but
with different weights other than one
over n
and with fewer points
and we're going to replace therefore
this function by the
very similar looking function where
we're evaluating these distances
so this this is the euclidean i don't
know if i even said the euclidean
distance
uh at uh at these new points
so now we have this new function and we
optimize
the new function and we get the point
which is not the empirically optimal
center
but what can we say about this new point
if we can get a guarantee if this point
at the maximum at the optimal at the
minimum
actually is within
eta within an approximation factor here
of the of the empirical risk there
then this construction is called the
corset so this this is the definition of
what
people in computational geometry refer
to by corsets
now if there are people actually working
with courses they say no this is not the
definition the definition actually
requires a uniform approximation over
all c's
and then this becomes a special case but
since this is the only part i'm going to
use you can just think of
this as the definition that let's not
complicate our life so we solve this
problem
we plug in in the actual the empirically
so again
of course at literature everything is
about the empirical risk
right so one of the steps we're going to
take here is to actually go from this
empirical risk
guarantee to the true risk the
generalization risk energy
so this is so in the early diagram
it was a statistical right so this is a
deterministic
this is about every realization of xr
right
yes so this is not an expectation yeah
yeah exactly
no this is for yeah but but but
the caveat i'm not going to i'm hiding
that a little bit
these constructions are probabilistic
themselves so
with high probability it will give you
this guarantee but now
let's forget about that huh okay it
actually
does give you that okay um
but beyond that no so this all of this
literature is about actual points and
you just just care about the points
there is no private distribution where
it's coming from so
you just give this guidance on the
points
so for me this is interesting because
it's about how can we approximate
when can we approximate the empirical
measure for a particular task
so but but we're going to use this as a
machinery
to get this computation statistics
trade-offs but the core set itself is a
randomized construction yes yes that's
what i was saying that this
this guarantee is going to be only true
with some probability
right so that's the question how much
computation does it take to compute the
core set
exactly so so this is the whole thing so
we have to see whether that it actually
buys us anything
so in terms of approximation so this
actually the whole thing is a motivation
of the
why to do approximation anyway in the
first place so you can think of this
presentation from a dual perspective
where
to motivate approximation of
this kind of results sketching etc
because
you can actually use it to balance and
then get some computational gain out of
it
and then that's great
okay so so how do we construct the
corsets
so now i'm not going to go in detail and
in fact i'm not a corset expert
i'm just using it as a tool
we have a bunch of points and you want
to create this summary
you will be first tempted to do uniform
sampling i don't know if you guys were
at woodruff david woodruff's talk on
monday he talked a little bit about
this choosing the different columns of a
matrix
was it rows of the matrix and so similar
idea so
you would be tempted to do uniform
something but that's not going to give
you the right kind of
balance because you will typically not
capture the right clusters because this
cluster is going
the rare the sparse clusters are going
to escape so the other idea
which people use is to do important
sampling and important sampling you can
think of it
it's typically done in this two-stage
fashion but as i will say later you can
actually do it in a streaming fashion
also
to do it online where you do a pass
imagine doing a pass on the data to
roughly see where the clusters are not
exactly solve the problem but roughly
from that you assign certain sampling
frequencies with your different points
and almost inversely proportionally you
assign them some weights
and then you sample based on the
sampling probabilities and you get in
the end
like a bunch of points here some points
there with the respective weights
and what people show is that this kind
of
constructions actually can give you the
corset guarantees so they
can actually give you a nice corset just
doing this important sampling
approach and what kind of properties
does it have to go back to see whether
we
what are what properties are we going to
use to extract some benefit out of it
the first thing is to see how does the
approximation factor depend on the
summarization size
so you can imagine with larger summaries
we get better approximation factors
small summaries worse approximation
factors but also this approximation
factor
the summary size is going to adversely
affect the construction the construction
time
and as i said it's typically divided
into two the first stage does not really
depend on the ultimate approximation
this first engine in fact is can be made
in time linear in the
end k and d which is great the second
part
only depends typically on the sampling
size but how many how much samples
you're going to extract
from your construction k is the number
of
centers the the model so the number of
centers and the k
means the k means
so why doesn't this depend on n it looks
like your approximation factor does not
depend on n
so this one you might as well choose n
equals k right but this is because what
yes but you've suffered there okay
but we're not messing with we're not
messing with k as we agree that
we're not messing with k we're fixed we
choose n equals s
yes but then you get n uh you get a
polynomial you get something worse off
there
and it was s uh
what happens when you do an equal s yeah
you get
you you guess yes exactly you get an
approximation yes
it's valid you can do that there's
nothing preventing you from doing that
but then and throws up there
which is going to screw us up if we if
you can if you do it
yeah there's no reason why you can't do
it okay
so this is how we can construct it now
the question is what is the final
picture look like so
just so that we don't get lost we have
some time
so we used to do data empirical risk
solve it get
empirical minimizers now we're going to
summarize the data
get the corset risk by the course of
this which now it only depends on the
summarization size we solve it
and then we get the corset sentence so
what's happening here is that
i'm keeping the solver the same so you
choose your solver whatever guarantees
it has
just give it to me and i'm going to use
it and then and then on the other hand
what you i'm going to incur as an
additional course
in addition to this to solve it on s i'm
going to get the summarization
cost running time
so so this is the picture we have in the
end this is what we're proposing about
doing
and then let's say and and not is the
sample complexity
when we ask for a trade-off what are we
asking for we're asking for
some at some point beyond the sample
complexity
we're asking for there to exist a
summarization which will guarantee us
the risk the tolerated risk
but simultaneously do better than just
truncating
okay so this is not then ultimately we
want to optimize this to drive it to
find the s which makes this as small as
possible
but for now we want some s which
actually at least goes below
just simple truncation
so this is the problem can we do it
and that's where we we arrived so
under some conditions mild conditions
um well well they are kind of might
because if you do if you if your
summarization is very time inefficient
okay what's the point of of summarizing
or if it
requires two minutes and so it's let's
say the summarization size
dependence on the summarization size is
just the same as this dependence of the
estimation error
then also you can nothing and if the
solver is not
sublinear or linear then why even bother
with any of this so you just use the
solver as this
so if these conditions are satisfied
then
what i'm saying is that there exists a
summarization there exists summarization
choices
which give you the trade-off that i
mentioned
this theorem sounds like a tautology
though
uh yes yes yes it does
see all happens and then you have a good
thing happening at the end the season
yeah
yes verify the conditions exactly so
this is
where you think we're perfectly
improving so that's why i'm saying that
these conditions but if but on the other
hand it's also the converse is also true
if they break you also can't do anything
so if they're verified you hope to do
something if they break you also do not
hope to do something
so then i can tell you a little bit
about the detail here we're saying the
summarization error is
dominated by the solver time running
time i'm sorry
and here we're saying that the
approximation factor
is growing slower than let's say you
plug in s there with estimation error
and then here there is a caveat about
the the risk should be small enough and
the sample size should be large enough
but that's the interesting regime
actually but what's interesting of
course is that these are satisfied these
conditions can be verified
to be satisfied by existing corset
constructions
so now this is interesting now we can
say trade-offs exist
and we get excited and then we realize
that what does it really mean that the
trade-off exists so it means that there
is
there is the summarization size where we
don't know exactly
what it is there is okay it might depend
on the model
can we actually get it so what it means
is that going back to our picture
and our nice flat line there it means
that
if i fix the data size there are a whole
bunch of summarizations and some of
which are going to go down
below that so that means that there is
some achievable running time
regime which is determined by
the by the summarization size
but and it means that an oracle could
potentially
find and tell me hey here you are
summarize it at this
level and if you summarize it at this
level you get the parito front the lower
priority front which is actually giving
you a trade-off that you desire but
can we get it can we get that right
summarization so this
is the next thing to us can we approach
this optimal
trade-off in some sense maybe not
optimal does it really look like this
because i would think that
it would start going up again if you
make the data too yeah okay excellent
support
we allow all the procedures to to to uh
to to truncate at some point if they
want to by definition
yeah huh by definition so by definition
in some sense but
but you it's a power that your procedure
has
okay and you factor in so now right now
i'm not talking about truncate and i'm
just talking about summarization you can
you really
can truncate summarize go ahead because
anyway there was the
nkd thing and the n was going to grow
eventually so you're right
so information theorist question yeah
but actually it's true i think i think i
saw one paper on corsets in information
3d transactions i haven't read it yet
but
i think
you know i mean there's this curve like
for a particular procedure
yeah so this is for the oracle so it's
an oracle so in
a priory we don't know whether any
procedure actual procedure can get it
but we want to do something something
more interesting than just guessing
and this actually a question about the
batches which we increase comes
comes in so what we can do the natural
thing what which we can do is we can
start with the summarization which is
very small
which is not going to give you the
epsilon tolerance that you want
and what we're going to do is that we're
going to increase
we do something that's a simple
exploration of the summarization space
where we try we start with some base
summarization and then
we grow it and at every step we test
whether we we have the risk
or not so a very natural thing to do and
then we in the end so i'll tell you
exactly how we increase
the summarization size and this test is
technically we have to assume validation
data but practically we just use some of
the data for validation
and uh and here the the growth should be
somehow
should should should mimic what your
solver your solver's complexity
so you have to in order to balance the
the the growth in time with the growth
with uh
so you see it will it will give you some
kind of geometric factor in front of the
optimal time
basically if you do it this way and uh
in the end we return when when the test
passes we return
the set of centers this test will depend
on some kind of
probability parameter that you have and
we can show this we can show something
which is not
too exciting because we suffer like if
you take the arithmetic
the the cost in terms of arithmetic
operation we actually squaring
compared to the optimal time so it's
so it's not perhaps great but it still
has the kind of
so this is the analysis that we did it
still eventually gives you
the a certain risk
what does it look like in practice in
practice
so this is with synthetic data with
syntax that are using some spherical
gaussians we do it
and we actually remarkably close to that
to the cartoon pictures that the that
i'm showing so
this is the this is the truncation this
is
the oracle and here we find these points
by searching over a whole bunch of
summarization so this actually is hard
to find the black and and red curves but
the blue curve is what the algorithm
gets
this this tram this trade-off navigation
algorithm
and if we do it now on real data
something funny happens with this
black line it's not flat anymore and
this is because the data is not really
id
i can tell you why uh offline but but
but then
we we search summarization we get tests
and then trump's latches to it pretty
well
doesn't really look like it's squaring
the time but so it's latching pretty
well
and this is some protein sorry this is
some protein data this is some seismic
detection data and this is this we ran
it
on so everything i present to you is k
means k means plus plus
and then but you can do the same concept
just to show that it's an actually
generalize
like the concept is generalizable so you
can actually go in in different ways
and since there are core sets for for uh
gaussian
mixture models we run we run it on this
yahoo web scope data
and then we got very similar performance
so in the end
we get three choices for the
practitioner either they can use their
entirety of the data
it takes forever to do it but then it
gives a very marginal gain in in
in the tolerated error or they can they
can
they can fix the risk and discard some
of the data but then
how do you do this exactly or you can
use this exploration
and summarization and solve it and then
you get some kind of guarantee
and some and nice practical behavior
just to wrap up now uh so what we've
done is that we have cr
we have created this paradigm of how to
get computation
statistics trade-offs using courses
summarization and we can navigate this
trade-off not just show that it exists
and corsets are i described to it as
two-step process but they're actually
very paralyzable and streamable and
uh and then it also they include the
space element in addition to time and
risk
and which we can actually explore in all
kinds of a variety of ways so i told you
one
this this way of how you can fix funding
vary something and tune another
space but you can actually imagine
exploring the space in many different
ways
but what's annoying is that corset to
find the right courses for different
problems is
kind of hard so and this is the
direction
which i think is very promising to sign
somehow find generic corsets which work
across across the board somehow
that's it
two quick questions about one are there
any noncritical lower bounds
in this problem
yeah lower bounds to the amount of
computation that you need
uh to achieve a certain absolute in
terms of
uh so there are there are lower bounds
in terms of the act
the the on the points themselves if you
want to solve it so that's why we can
say it and be hard etcetera
but but in terms of if you allow
yourself to trade off computational
aesthetics i don't know
i don't think so maybe one more concrete
question would be
in your plot of the curve if you were to
give yourself
infinite data yeah would you ever be
able to drive the
zero no so eventually so these pictures
these pictures uh i don't so no
because there's the modeling error you
you know
okay it's not a simple no so there is a
justification behind it
but uh but but the reason is that at
some point you have so much data that
really there's no point in the
basically you have the distribution
function and then there is some
computation associated with just looking
at the distribution
and then finding the answer right so you
cannot really get to zero in terms of
computation you get to some
plateau and then actually cerebral and
the others have called this the the
data laden regime so you have a lot of
data and then before it's the data
what is the data laid in data scarce
that's called
the data scarce regime data latent
regime in the mid
middle something interesting happens
it's the intermediate regime that's a
good question
related to the last bullet for the
cayman's
k-means problem yeah how much is the
core set result that you quoted
uh depending on the euclidean did i
mention d
no no the the other trick was the
equating
yes yes that result uh
dependent on that so it depends because
now if you want to go to k media in
general you have to prove the entire
whole bunch of new corset results so
there are some generic methods
by criteria approximation methods uh by
feldman so that paper that i said in
2011 stock paper they talk about how can
you generally prove
but you have to prove it again i mean
they tell you how to do it but then you
change the metric you have to prove it
again
so it would be nice to do it without
having to prove it again every time
so have you looked at these for convex
optimization problems where you could
put numbers and
rates and so on to all these different
terms and compare
um no but uh so
i think in the complex problems you
would do something like sketching maybe
then courses so i imagine if we lift the
results from scatter
what people do in sketching maybe we can
get we can do that but no i haven't done
it
i just i just just looked at the k-means
problem i
it wasn't even clear whether we're going
to gain anything even here so it was i
was happy to see that yes something
happens
not just by theory also also on the data
that we're collecting
so your summarization involves
randomization
right uh yes so yes
so imagine everything i presented is
conditioned on the events that the
corset is good
so is there some better result saying
that to really achieve better trade-offs
than
you know looking at all the data and
doing
the empirical obvious thing you would
always need randomization
i don't think i don't think so actually
it would be nice to have none
i there might i think i've seen a couple
of results about non-randomized corset
constructions
you just have to replace this election
that you're doing this
with some kind of
yeah i'm not really sure because you you
explore
you decide that oh these places i have
to sample more this place i have to
sample less but then
all the analysis relies on the nice
probabilistic properties that you get
from the sampling
and then you you have to replace that
you have to de-randomize somehow
i'm not sure
so related questions so what if you
tried a few rounds of soft
s means and use that as
the corset
uh well that's almost like the
truncation so i yes you're adding a
little bit by
it's not exactly so
if you do a few rounds of soft test
means still you're getting a
more representative sample than just
it's a good suggestion i don't know of
the top of my head i don't know what
what to say
but it's interesting okay
punch